[Music]
thank you
one of the important and indeed very
dramatic plot points of Philip K Dick's
novel The Man in the High Castle has to
do with an attack that's carried out
within the Pacific States of America on
the Nippon Times building by the SD the
sicker Deans hide these these police
that are being used by the Nazis to
interfere with business on the side of
the border right in the Japanese
territory and there's a really important
meeting that is taking place about
operation dandelion as we find out
between Wagner who is an opera operative
that's Naval Counter Intelligence and
general tadaki who is supposed to be
retired but actually still has a very
important role within the Japanese
government particularly in relation to
military matters and they're having this
secretly at the Nippon Times building
organized under a cover by tagomi who is
you know a trade executive and so this
provides a certain sort of blind you
could say but the Nazi authorities are
wise to this and so prior to the attack
we see several different going back and
forth about the real fegner guy by these
two important Nazi officials who are
often at
counter purposes with each other the SD
Chief
phonemeira and Christopher and the
reichs council rice and so in um
a little bit before this in chapter 11
we have this discussion going on between
them and kreutzfone Mara says
um
you know we're going to get this Wagner
guy he's on his way to this appointment
we have to pick him up there on the Spot
Run in grab him run out and rice
supposes an appointment is with some
extremely high place officials there
may be an Emperor's personal
representative in San Francisco right
now and creates familiar says it doesn't
matter he's a German National subject to
reich's law I have a Commando Squad
ready five good men they'll get in and
they'll walk right up to the door
they're dressed just right pretty much
as you are
Right In Plain Sight broad daylight up
to this Wagner gather around him appear
to con be conferring message of
importance no violence just hear Wagner
come with us please you understand and
between the vertebrae of his spine a
little shaft a pump upper ganglia
paralyzed then out again back to the car
back to my office the Japs will make a
lot of Racket but polite to the last so
that he's making fun of them and then um
there's a call that comes in to rice and
it's from the highest level of the
German Reich from the chancellor himself
gibbles in this case who's just taken
power and saying that you are to
cooperate with the SD chief on this and
um kreuz Von Maris says write out an
authorization for us to return this
Wagner to Germany forcibly and they do
that and then he says now when the
Japanese authorities call you and
complain and if they do and Christopher
mayor says they will they'll be here
within 15 minutes of the time we pick
this Wagner up and he says you can tell
the Japs he's a homosexual or forger or
something like that wanted for a major
crime back home don't tell them he's
wanted for political crimes you know
they don't recognize 90 percent of
National Socialist law and so creates
one mayor is going to go and take care
of this and
um the reichs council thinks about this
you know what am I going to do in this
case and he says it might be worth
seeing how a little foot dragging here
and there could possibly stall your
activities here pull its eye through or
something negative that could never be
pinned down for instance when the
Japanese come in here to complain I
might manage to drop a hint as to the
Lufthansa flight on which his fellows to
be dragged away or barring that needle
them into a bit more outrage by just the
trace of a content to a smirk suggesting
the Reich is amused by them doesn't take
little yellow men seriously and if they
get angry enough they might carry it
directly to gerbils all sorts of
possibilities the SD can't really get
this fellow out of the PSA without my
active cooperation if only I can hit on
precisely the right twist and
what's his motivation he says I don't
like people who go over my head right so
the Commando Squad is ready rice has
said that he is going to handle the
Japanese they've got kind of a division
of labor going on here and then we get
to the Fateful chapter 12 where the
attack is being discussed so the desk
intercom buzzed Mr tagomi pressed the
button Mr Ramsey his assistant's voice
came sir there's a group of SD men in
the downstairs Lobby they're attempting
to take over the building the times
guards are scuffling with them it goes
on Army MPS are on the way plus the San
Francisco kempiti the police right and
so Mr tagumi says Thank you Mr Ramsey
you have done an honorable thing to
report placidly and he says to Baines
and general tedeki sirs we will no doubt
kill the SD thugs before they reach this
floor and then he tells Mr Ramsey turn
off the power to the elevators and they
do do that and then Mr tuomi says we're
going to wait and then here's what
happens
he opened his desk drawer and lifted out
a Teakwood box unlocking it he brought
forth a perfectly preserved U.S 1860
Civil War Colt 44 a treasured
collector's item one of the things that
he's bought from uh the you know
Antiquities American Antiquities store
run by Robert childen
taking out a box of loose powder ball
and cap ammunition he began loading the
revolver Mr Baines and general tadecki
watched wide-eyed part of a personal
collection Mr tagomi said much fooled
around in vainglorious Swift draw
practicing and firing in spare hours
admit to compare favorably with other
enthusiasts and contest timing but
mature use heretofore delayed holding
the gun in correct fashion he pointed it
at the office door and sat waiting and
we find that he's able to use this gun
to take out the two remaining SD guards
for 20 minutes Mr tagomi had rain
remained motionless at his desk holding
the revolver pointed at the door and we
find that they put in some calls
tadaki calls Tokyo
um first the Japanese Embassy now he's
placing a trans-pacific call to Tokyo he
says I will consult with the war College
they will contact Imperial military
forces stationed near bias and tagomi
thanks so we'll be relieved in a couple
of hours maybe Japanese Marines from a
carrier armed with machine guns and
mortars but that's going to be quite a
while right and then there's a call that
they place to the German Consul and
they're like let's make this really
dramatic and so to go me uh calls and he
says I'm ordering the arrest and trial
of your band of Cutthroats and
degenerates who run amok like blonde
berserk beasts unfit to even describe do
you know me Carol this is tagomi
Imperial government consultant five
seconds or wave legality and have the
Marine shock trip unit begin Massacre
with flame throwing phosphorus bombs
disgrace to civilization he doesn't
actually have the console he's just got
some SD flunky right actually he's
calling kreutz from from Mara and so it
doesn't actually work out he's not going
to get a result from this and then the
SD men come in
two Burly white men appeared both armed
with pistols equipped with silencers
they made out Mr Byrne Baines
dasastair once said they started for Mr
Baines that means that's that's the guy
at his desk Mr tagomi pointed his Colt
44 ancient collector's item and
compressed the trigger one of the SD men
fell to the floor the other whipped his
silencer equipped gun towards Mr tagomi
and returned fire Mr tagumi heard no
report saw only a tiny wisp of smoke
from the gun heard the whistle of a slug
passing near with record eclipsing speed
he fanned the Hammer of the single
action cult firing it again and again
and we have this gruesome description
the SD man's jaw burst bits of bone
flesh shreds of tooth flew in the air
hit in the mouth Mr tagomi realized
Dreadful spot especially if ball
ascending the jawless SD Man's eyes
still contained life of a kind he still
perceives me Mr tagomi thought then his
eyes lost their Foster and the SD man
collapsed dropping his gun and making
unhuman gargling noises no more SD men
appeared in the open doorway possibly it
is over General dadecki said after a
pause Mr tagomi engaged in tedious
three-minute task of reloading pause to
press the button of the desk intercom
bring medical emergency aid hideously
injured Thug here
and then uh they they come in and in the
hall a voice called German hoodlums
surrender and Mr tugami says already
taken care of lying either dead or dying
advance and verify empirically so what
what's happened you know the crisis
seems to be over but
this is actually going to place
Mr tagomi himself into a crisis as we
see he has had to kill two men in order
to save one albeit one who's got a very
important Mission but who's already
carried out his mission
and this lies very heavily upon him and
he begins casting the Euro stocks for
the Oracle to find out what um he ought
to do to to come back to some sort of
balance to decki then says he'll regain
his equilibrium in time right now he has
no standpoint by which he can view and
comprehend his act the book will help
him for it provides an external frame of
reference
then going on uh we find that there's an
aftermath for tagomi
he doesn't get an answer from the Oracle
that he needs and he says yet I must
must go on living day to day anyhow I
will go and find the small live unseen
at any rate until some later time
he doesn't go to the Nippon Times
building as usual
uh why not he thinks to himself I can
never go back to the Nippon Times
building perhaps with its stink of death
my career is over but just as well a
replacement can be found by the Board of
Trade Mission activities and but tagomi
still walks exists recalling every
detail of the killing that he had to do
so nothing is accomplished hopeless
wherever one looks and then of course he
has this interesting experience which is
facilitated in part by his attempt to
sell or resell the pistol back to its
original seller Mr Children right who
won't accept it but who does sell
um tagomi a new piece of jewelry by
Frank Frank and he has a very
interesting experience as a result of
that which we'll talk about elsewhere
the other thing that happens in chapter
14 is a very interesting confrontation
with the German Consul and first
he you know he tells him that uh you
know I know what all of you did uh and
rice shows up at his office and tagumi
says before you begin litany let me
speak I personally shot your SD men and
then rice says the San Francisco Police
Department summoned me for hours I'd
been down at the Kearney Street Station
in the morgue and I've been reading over
the account your people gave to the
investigating police inspectors
absolutely Dreadful this from start to
finish so this is part of his handling
the Japanese and then he says however
the contention that the hoodlums are
connected with the Reich hasn't been
established as far as I'm concerned the
whole matter is insane I'm sure you
acted absolutely properly Mr tagori
tagomi and then he says my hand let's
shake a gentleman's agreement to drop
this it's unworthy especially in these
critical times when any stupid publicity
might inflame the mob mind to the
detriment of our nation's interests and
so what we see here is that Rice wants
to bury this issue he's already
disavowed responsibility and tagomi says
something here very interesting he's no
longer acting as something like a
diplomat
he says guilt is never the is
nonetheless on my soul blood hair rice
can never be eradicated like ink I crave
forgiveness you cannot give it to me
though possibly no one can I intend to
read famous diary by Massachusetts
ancient Divine Goodman see Mather deals
I am told with guilt and hellfire at
Alia and then he tells them
allow me to notify you your nation is
about to descend into greater vileness
than ever I declare heart sick with
horror bloodbath coming beyond all
compare yet even now you strive for some
slight egotistical gain or goal put one
over on Rival facts in the SDA well you
get hair B creutz from Marin hot water
his chest had become constricted right
he says I am suffering of malady growing
these long years but which entered
virulent form the day I heard helplessly
your leaders escapades recited anyhow
therapeutic possibility nil for you too
sir in language of good men see Mather
of properly recalled repent
and so he's uh placing everything on a
very different level the result of this
attack it's no longer just a diplomatic
incident it has to do with good and evil
particularly evil itself
and the council says you're holding me
responsible for General conditions
beyond my jurisdiction and Mr tagomi
says chicken I say to that and the
council says this is not the way
civilized individuals conduct business
you're making this all bitter and
vindictive where it ought to be mere
formality with no personality embroiled
right all of this sort of machination
behind the scenes and to gomi says take
your false stinking cigarette along and
he basically kicks him out now he's
going to suffer a minor heart attack
after that but there's one other thing
that's really important that happens
here that shows us a little bit of
tagomi's views on these matters
and
um
the the German Consul says here's a
routine matter it's a request by the
Reich through the representative and the
Pacific States of America for remand of
fella now in custody of San Francisco
Police Department Jew named Frank Fink
citizen of Germany retroactive June 1960
for productive protective custody under
reich's law and Mr tagomi takes the form
grabs it scribbles on the bottom release
ranking trade Mission San Francisco
Authority
military protocol
1947 and so this results in Frank Frank
not being tortured and executed and in
fact being saved now tagomi doesn't know
Frank from Adam so to speak but he's had
this interesting experience due to
Frank's jewelry so there's all these
interesting subplots woven together in
the this SD attack that takes place
trying to get Rudolph Wegner also
putting tagomi and tedeki in Jeopardy as
well to gomi turns out to be kind of a
hero but a reluctant and guilt-ridden
one for having to take the life of The
Killers who otherwise would have killed
them so very important subplot that's
taking place here that is revelatory not
just of action but of character